Anastacia is a heartfelt story of a
journey back home
but the truth is the real-life version
is nothing like you've seen in movies
state at the end to find out how
Anastasia sparked a 90 year long
investigation if you're new here make
sure to subscribe to the things and give
our video a big thumbs up now let's
check out the disturbing real story
behind Anastasia the actual version
let's first talk about the movie version
we all know in love Anastasia isn't your
typical princess movie and the story
itself focuses on the history way more
than any other heartfelt princess movie
ever made Anastasia was the last
surviving child of the Russian royal
family and in order to be reunited with
her grandmother she joins two conmen to
escape rasputin's who wants to end her
life in the 10-year long process
Anastasia also finds the love of her
life and eventually becomes reunited
with her grandmother none of the people
knows she's actually the real Anastasia
but 10 years after the siege rumors
spread that she might still be alive
the story is pretty intense and full of
interesting moments however it's also
full of historical inaccuracies that had
nothing to do with how the real story of
Anastasia actually unfolded real story
before we talk about the actual story we
should probably mention that Anastasia
was never a Disney Princess until now
this seems to confuse a lot of people
but the truth is Anastasia was one of
the few princess worthy movies that was
produced by Walt Disney but distributed
by 20th Century Fox not Disney and 2015
Disney finally bought and stages rights
and after all these years she finally
joined the ranks of their Disney
Princesses but there's more to the
actual storyline of this movie than you
might actually know Anastasia was
actually a real tragedy the filmmakers
might have decided to totally change her
story but the truth is a lot of people
don't know the disturbing real deal of
the real life of anesthesia that
actually has nothing to do with
Anastasia herself and everything to do
with the royal family Russia and abroad
world 1 let's first begin with some
background information
Anastasia's story begins in the 18th
century when Europe was one of the most
powerful continents in the world it's a
painful tale of a family that had to go
through way too much almost every
country had a royal family and most of
these families were related to one
another with a lot of political agendas
and liberal reforms came a lot of
assassinations that were often witnessed
by kids it really wasn't a pretty sight
and it definitely isn't anything that a
heartfelt Disney movie would actually
show in 1913 the Romanovs celebrated 300
years on Russians throne and the Russian
royal children were pretty popular the
Emperor had four daughters named Olga
Tatiana Maria and Anastasia who were
absolutely gorgeous but when their
youngest daughter Anastasia was born the
Emperor's were disappointed they were
hoping for a son that that would take
the throne
however Anastasia was often described as
a bright and cheerful child who was also
a pretty good prankster according to the
history books it's been noted that she
would often trip servants trick her
teachers and she even camouflaged a rock
into a snow ball during a snowball fight
she seemed like a pretty normal kid
right but since daughters weren't able
to be the heirs to the throne the crown
went to the youngest brother Alexei but
what society didn't know was that Alexei
had hemophilia which is a disease that
causes bleeding joints because of that
reason
Alexei had to be carried just about
everywhere until the disease ultimately
ended his life his death crushed the
family and things seemed to have taken a
darker turn after of course the story
doesn't stop there but remember
Anastasia isn't the main character in
this tale after the first world war
Liberal government temporarily came to
power and everyone seems to have been
relieved but only a couple of months
later the government was violently
overthrown
the Communist Party sees the power to
the throne and the process of this
violence sees the imperial family which
also included a teenage Anastasia was
killed the family was brought in a cold
basement under the promise of being
protected but instead of being safe the
executioner's ended the lives of every
single member of the family including
the dog
yep that's right the real Anastasia
wasn't the last surviving member she
didn't go on a decade-long quest to
reunite with her grandmother the truth
was she was brutally killed and her life
ended with a message but she wasn't the
only one tens of millions of others have
died along with her in this process of
this violent government seized and it's
known as one of the cruelest acts of the
century the dynasty came to an end the
message was sent to the world that the
revolution would go forward under the
communist party 90 year old mystery but
Anastasia's story comes with even more
mystery to it and there is a valid
reason why the movie version of her
story changed the narrative in the years
following the execution
I first started wondering whether
Anastasia and her youngest brother were
actually still alive many people came
forward stating that they are actually
the Grand Duchess as I said she was
still alive because she was shielded by
family jewels sewn into the clothing for
safekeeping while this doesn't seem
likely it definitely sparked plenty of
rumors and investigations in 1991 the
forensic team identified Anastasia's
family members and servants however
Anastasia's and her brother's body were
still nowhere to be found pretty weird
right
Anastasia's mystery inspired books plays
and movies which is precisely why 20th
Century Fox gave a happy ending for her
story but the 90 year old mystery came
to an end in 2007 when a new DNA
analysis conclusively identified the
body
Anastacia and Alexi they were found in
the site nearby still close to the
families and that's the real disturbing
story of Anastasia that's it for our
video don't forget to subscribe to the
things and hit that like button for more
videos like this one see you next time
[Music]